yo nací en 1978 en un país convulsionado
en un país polarizado en un país en
guerra como el país en el que nacieron
la mayoría de las personas que estamos
hoy aquí reunidas
pero nací en una familia particular mi
padre y mi madre fueron insurgentes
fueron guerrilleros urbanos del
movimiento 19 de abril yo nací en la
clandestinidad el 31 de diciembre de
1978 el m-19 se robó 5 mil armas de una
guarnición militar del ejército
eso supuso para todos nosotros el inicio
de una etapa de persecución y de guerra
de allanamientos de detenciones
cualquier persona que fuese sindicada de
ser militante o simpatizante o familiar
de algún miembro del m-19 era
inmediatamente detenido gabriel garcía
márquez por ejemplo tuvo que exiliarse
en esos años porque se decía era
militante del movimiento 19 de abril en
mi casa allanaron simultáneamente cinco
casas al mismo tiempo nuestros recuerdos
nuestra vida nuestros álbumes todo
terminó en unas bolsas de basura en
algún guarnición o en ninguna guarnición
militar
y pase
y empezaron los interrogatorios
llegamos a la
de tensión mis padres fueron detenidos y
llevados a la base militar de cimitarra
allí fueron torturados durante 26 días
y ahí fueron trasladados a la cárcel y
yo pasé los tres primeros años de mi
vida entrando a la cárcel mi madre
estaba detenida en bucaramanga mi padre
estaba detenido en bogotá y yo el primer
domingo de cada mes como lo hacen la
mayoría de los presos y de los hijos de
los presos políticos vamos a visitar a
nuestros padres ellos pues convirtieron
la cárcel en un espacio de alegría yo
creo que esta fue la magia que pudimos
de alguna manera sobrellevar esos años
porque ellos hacían de cada domingo un
lugar de fiesta y un lugar de amor
salieron de las cárceles las puertas se
abrieron en 1982 con la amnistía general
de belisario betancur allí fue el
momento del reencuentro viajamos a cuba-
allí estuvimos unos meses
teniendo pues como el único espacio
familiar que se nos permitió en esos
años de vi cotidianidad de compartir
la decisión del m-19 fue devolver a la
lucha armada y eso supuso nuevamente la
persecución esta vez nosotros pues
éramos utilizados como botines de guerra
nos perseguían para detener a nuestros
padres yo tuve que salir del país a los
7 años y exiliada política en francia
regresé dos años después a los quince
días de mi regreso
como estaba secuestrado álvaro gómez y
mi padre en ese momento ya era
comandante del movimiento 19 de abril
a los 15 días teníamos policías vestidos
de civil rodeando la casa llamaban a la
casa y decían ustedes tienen algo que
nosotros queremos y ese algo era yo
vendimos lo que pudimos mi mamá puso un
letrero en el periódico que decía se
vende casa motivo viaje salimos
inmediatamente a la frontera más cercana
a ecuador a intentar reconstruir nuestra
vida ahí perdí mi identidad nuevamente y
unos meses después mi padre nos encontró
no sabía dónde estábamos nos buscó y nos
dijo que quería que pasáramos con él las
fiestas de navidad salimos hacia
colombia las montañas de colombia
llegamos a una finca allí pasamos la
segunda y última navidad que pasé con mi
padre en mi vida y ahí nos dijo que
estaba comprometido con firmar la paz
que creía que el camino del desangre ya
no era el espacio que se merecía
colombia y que no estaba dispuesto a
contribuir en la guerra
nos devolvimos a ecuador para regresar a
colombia el 9 de marzo de 1990 mi padre
carlos pizarro leongómez firmó la paz
con el gobierno de virgilio barco fue el
primer proceso de paz exitoso en
colombia y en américa latina'
inmediatamente arrancó una campaña
maratónica en un mes de campaña ya tenía
el 60 por ciento de intención de voto
claramente se perfilaba como uno de los
posibles ganadores
y el 26 de abril 45 días después de
firmar la paz cuando iniciaba su gira
por el caribe tomando un avión a
barranquilla en un vuelo comercial de
avianca fue asesinado en un avión en
pleno vuelo 15 tiros a manos de
sicario de medellín de alguna de estas
comunas de medellín y él fue utilizado
como gatillero colombia perdió yo creo
la esperanza de iniciar en ese momento
la construcción o la posibilidad de la
paz la noche antes de que lo mataran nos
reunimos en un restaurante
mi hermana le dijo carlos tú no te estás
poniendo el chaleco antibalas y papá le
dijo si me van a pegar si van a matar me
pegan un tiro en la cabeza el chaleco
antibalas no me sirve para nada me dijo
a mí me van a matar muy pronto por favor
mi amor no me olvides y esa fue la
última vez que yo lo hice
para mí la paz fue dolorosa como lo es
hoy muy seguramente para cientos los
cientos de familias de los líderes que
están siendo asesinados o de los
combatientes de las farc que están
siendo asesinados y ahí inicio yo creo
un camino
en solitario profundo yo a los 18 años
decidí irme a viajar por suramérica con
mi perro
este país me dolía demasiado
yo miraba el mapa y decía colombia está
demasiado cerca yo tengo que irme más
lejos
y sobrevivir cuatro años como lo hacen
muchísimos vendedores ambulantes en este
país
o las personas que se paran en los
semáforos
recorrí todo el continente con mis
perros se llamaba libertad
hablé con mujeres con campesinos con
personas que sobreviven con muchísimas
dificultades en este continente entendí
que la pobreza aún no solo la entiende
cuando la biblia que es muy difícil
imaginarse cuál la de cuál es la
realidad de estas personas si tú no lo
estás viviendo
las prostitutas brasileñas por ejemplo
yo estaba embarazada me regalaron la
ropa que le puse la primera ropa que le
puse a mis hijas y lo hice con todo el
orgullo porque sabía que era el esfuerzo
y las mujeres trabajadoras que se
levantaban y que cada noche tenían que
pasar por circunstancias muy muy
adversas
en ese embarazo
y decidí regresar a colombia llegué
con mi hija muy pequeña y tuvimos que
salir del país a los dos años por
amenazas yo no quería que mi hija pasara
por lo mismo que había pasado yo creía
que nos merecíamos un instante de paz y
de sosiego y que ella pudiera crecer en
un entorno diferente al de polarización
que continuaba existiendo en estos años
salimos a barcelona españa ese fue mi
país de acogida allí estuve en el exilio
ocho años y en medio de esas calles que
no les recuerdan uno nada donde no hay
memoria si no hay recuerdos en cada
esquina
y yo empecé a preguntarme por mi propia
vida y la relación estrecha que hay
entre mi vida personal y la historia de
este país y quise conocer a mi padre
allí trabajaba como cualquier inmigrante
como las miles de mujeres inmigrantes
que salen de
de estos países nuestros a buscarse la
vida en otros lugares limpiando casas
cuidando niños lavando platos
y se me dio la oportunidad de estudiar
artes plásticas con énfasis en joyería
artística
eso quiere decir concebir la joya como
un objeto de arte
y me acordé de 100 años de soledad que
es uno de mis libros favoritos cuando el
coronel aureliano buendía dice que se
requiere tal nivel de concentración para
soldar una escama de un pescadito de oro
que uno olvida los horrores de la guerra
mientras yo estaba así en mi pequeño
taller de alquimia escuchaba la voz de
mi padre leía periódicos vídeos comencé
a hacer entrevistas empecé a hablar con
políticos con ex militares con mi
familia con compañeros del m-19 y empecé
a construir un padre para guardarlo
dentro de mí ese fue un proceso
individual de búsqueda que se fue
convirtiendo en un proceso colectivo
porque muchos de los excombatientes del
m-19 no habían vuelto a pensar en su
propia historia y no habían encontrado
un lugar como narrar sus historias al
país
decidí entonces empezar a luchar por por
mi identidad quería constituirse como
parte civil en el caso por el asesinato
de mi padre pero como no tenía una
afiliación no podía hacer ese proceso
para recuperar mi identidad duró cinco
años a pesar de las fotos de las cartas
nada le valió a la justicia exhumamos el
cadáver de mi padre se realizaron las
pruebas de adn se demostró con ese 99 9%
que yo era hija de carlos pizarro puede
llamarme maría josé pizarro y coincidió
ese momento con mi retorno al país ocho
años después regresé con mi historia y
con mi vida y cuestas con la decisión
política de hacer pública mi historia de
contarle a este país cuál era esa otra
historia que no hacía parte de la
narrativa nacional que es posible
humanizar al enemigo aquel que te han
dicho que debes odiar y al que es
posible hacerle de todo
empecé a mostrarle al país que no era
necesario justificar lo injustificable y
que nosotros teníamos que tener una
posición crítica frente a nuestra propia
historia realice documentales
uno de ellos uno de los más premiados
que tiene el país exposiciones que
recorrieron varias ciudades de colombia
actos colectivos por la memoria retornos
simbólicos
inicie pues digamos un camino muy
personal que se convirtió de alguna
manera en una metodología mientras esto
sucedía yo luchaba contra la impunidad
litigue en los juzgados en los medios de
comunicación logré que el crimen por el
asesinato de mi padre se declarara
crimen de lesa humanidad y esa
metodología mía
fue de alguna manera convocada por el
centro nacional de memoria histórica ahí
estuve cinco años recorriendo el país
aplicando esto a otras experiencias
en el boom de la memoria o en el boom de
la reconciliación y hay que tener en
cuenta que en ese 2010
hablar de la memoria de la insurgencia
armada a hablar de un pasado guerrillero
hablar de
de estas otras historias que han estado
ocultas eran una herejía hasta hablar de
paz y reconciliación en ese momento era
una herejía pero como yo miles de
personas iniciaron ese camino empecé a
recorrer este país ya las montañas del
cauca con los indígenas y entendéis su
lucha por el territorio vine aquí a las
comunas de medellín trabajé mucho en la
comuna 13 con la escombrera estuve en
los montes de maría estuve en bojayá
allí reconstruimos con mi fundación la
iglesia de ohio la comunidad estaba
destrozada porque la iglesia se caía y
era importantísimo poderle decir a este
país hacer un acto de
de reconciliación en un espacio de
dignidad finalmente tomamos la decisión
colectiva de lanzarnos a la política
porque tenemos que ocupar otros espacios
y la lucha por la memoria y la dignidad
no son el único espacio y allí
obviamente en esta carrera que fue
maratónica hicimos una campaña austera
estuvimos en la calle con la gente
planteamos cuáles son los requerimientos
de nuestra generación que es necesario
hablar con absolutamente todos para
poder reconstruir este país que es una
responsabilidad que nos pertoca a todos
y a todas que debemos ser sujetos
activos creo que si yo logre llegar al
congreso a la república con la cuarta
votación más alta en bogotá 80.000 votos
quiere decir que otros como yo pueden
animarse y ver que ese es un espacio de
transformación social nosotros
básicamente que queremos nosotros
queremos heredarle a nuestros hijos un
país distinto al que recibimos nosotros
creo que queremos poder hacer lo que tal
vez nuestros padres y miles de personas
en este país no han podido hacer que es
poder florecer poder envejecer en un
país completamente diferente renovado y
al cual nosotros hayamos podido aportar
a su transformación gracias muchas
gracias